good afternoon and welcome the National
Press Club my name is Gregory Spears and
I'm president of the National Press Club
and Washington correspondent for three
night reader newspapers in Florida the
Braden Harold the Tallahassee Democrat
and the news of Boca Raton I'd like to
welcome my fellow Club members and
guests in the audience today as well as
our Award winners and our judges in our
awards contests plus those of you who
are listening to this program over one
of the more than 400 national public
radio stations or watching on one of the
4,200 cable systems affiliated with
c-span before introducing the guests at
our head table I would like to remind
our members of some coming events this
Friday June 26 Sir Edmund Hillary will
be our speaker for the National Press
Club environmental awards luncheon on
June 30th Robert Crandall chairman of
American Airlines will be here on July
1st Public Broadcasting System president
Bruce Christiansen will be here and on
July 2nd the Prime Minister of Japan
will be here to speak about us Japanese
relations Audient Apes of press pub
luncheons are available through the
National Press Club library or by
calling 1-800 nine five to tape I'd also
like to remind our guests here today
that if you have any questions for our
speakers and I'm sure you will please
write them on the cards provided at your
table and pass them up to me and I'll
ask as many as time permits I'd like now
to introduce the head table guests and
ask them to please stand briefly when
their names are read I also ask the
audience to withhold any applause until
I write all the names and I'm going to
start at my left and your right
Nancy done the Financial Times of London
Lawrence taishoff chairman of
broadcasting magazine rim writer
publisher of Washington Journalism
Review Clark Hoyt Washington bureau
chief of night returned newspapers and
chairman of the National Press
Foundation Allen Adams editor of
research recommendations and Secretary
of the Board of Governors of the
National Press Club I'm going to skip
over our speakers for the moment go to
Clayton voice deputy news editor
knight-ridder tribune newswire and vice
president of the National Press Club
John Peterson chairman of the National
Press Club speakers committee Harry
Stouffer the Pittsburgh post-gazette and
chairman of the awards committee Charles
Alexander the director of the Medill
News Service in Washington DC
Leland Schwartz the publisher of States
News Service
and James McTigue Washington bureau
chief of the American Banker today we're
welcoming to the National Press Club two
of the most honored reporters of our day
Donald Barletta and James Steele they
have worked together as a team of
investigative reporters for the
Philadelphia Inquirer since 1971 their
specialty is researching analyzing and
writing in-depth series of stories about
complex issues and institutions that
profoundly affect American lives they
have won virtually every major national
journalism award for their investigative
reports including two Pulitzer Prizes
for national reporting their first
Pulitzer in 1975 was for a series of
articles called auditing the IRS which
detailed the inequities of an Internal
Revenue Service audits their second
Pulitzer in 1989 was for a series titled
the great tax giveaway in 7 installments
they told how members of Congress had
salted hundreds of secret tax breaks for
favored constituents into the Tax Reform
Act of 1986 in his book the new
muckrakers
Leonard Downey jr. said the journalism
of Barlett and Steele quote represents a
significant step beyond traditional
muckraking instead of just reporting
still unproven allegations and focusing
on individual corruption they reveal
with expert analysis and thorough
documentation what has systematically
gone wrong with the powerful complex
institutions that affect so much of life
today it is said that they follow the
maxim of the Great Wall Street Journal
editor Barney Kilgore that for every
inch of copy in one of their stories
there be an inch or more thick
of supporting documentation back in the
office and their cramped office has no
clear space anywhere according to an
Inquirer colleague who calls it quote an
organized mess they are here to talk
about their last published work a series
of stories titled America what went
wrong the series concluded that the
public's perception that something was
wrong with the American economy was
right that unbridled greed on Wall
Street and deal-making here in
Washington was destroying industries
that million of millions of people
relied upon for their livelihoods after
its publication last October there were
400 thousand requests for reprints of
the series and an expanded version of
the series was published in softcover
this year two highly favorable reviews
the Los Angeles Times said this
important and profoundly disturbing book
should be required reading for voters in
the upcoming elections and this just in
an AP story on what Ross Perot reads he
gives it rave reviews he said I read it
from the Philadelphia paper the first
time and it is world-class everybody
should read it Perot said I hope that
nobody that reads it can live with it
he also said ladies and gentlemen please
welcome Don varlet and Jim Steele
I don't know how to respond to that one
of the questions that we were all we've
been asked quite frequently is how the
series began and it was published about
two weeks before the election last
November and we received a few letters
and a few phone calls afterwards
questioning whether or not the Enquirer
had engaged in a conspiracy to secure
the election of Harris Wofford
and obviously anybody who's ever been in
the Enquirer newsroom knows that the
terms conspiracy and Inquirer newsroom
are mutually exclusive that's not
possible
but we had a number of these questions
and finally we told one person yes
you're right it was a conspiracy it
began in August of 1989 when we wanted
to see gene Roberts who was in the
editor The Enquirer and we said look
you're not going to believe this but we
have it on good authority that in April
of 1991 senator Heinz is going to die in
a helicopter plane crash and dick
thornburgh is going to resign his
Attorney General and run for Senator
Heinz's seat that November and this guy
named Harris Wofford is going to run
against him and nobody knows him and we
want to make sure he wins the election
so we'd like to spend the next 20 months
working on next two years working on
this and Robert said sure go ahead take
whatever time you need it's no problem
that wasn't really how it began but if
that satisfies conspiracists okay it
really began like everything we've ever
done has begun with a simple single
question what was happening to people
who worked for companies that underwent
restructuring and with that question
we'd set out across the country
beginning in late 89 and continuing
through 90 Jim would go to a Martell
California interview a sawmill worker
I'd interview a department store clerk
in Charleston West Virginia
he didn't review someone who worked for
a meatpacking meat processing plant in
Sedalia Missouri and I didn't
view middle level manager in Niles
Michigan at a manufacturing plant this
went on and on and every time we came
back and transcribed the notes we saw
something we had never seen before in
all the years in this business the
interviews were identical
it didn't matter whether the person was
white collar or blue collar white black
or Hispanic high school dropout
college-educated it made no difference
the responses were generally the same
people were being forced into ever lower
paying jobs they were losing all or part
of their healthcare benefits they were
forced to pay for a larger percentage of
their what health care for those people
who kept it they were losing all or part
of their pensions or their future
retirement benefits were in question at
the same time the interviews were going
on were doing a lot of statistical work
and we and we picked up very quickly
that the statistics were showing that
these weren't aberrations that we just
hadn't happened to settle on the right
people in two dozen states in two
thousand different cities and that these
were more than anecdotes but they really
fell into a broad pattern as to what was
happening in the economy we have to
point out it obviously there are those
people who disagree with with some of
the conclusions we've drawn from the
statistics one of the kind of fun things
we've had if over the years of working
together and because so much of what we
do is Washington based we're thinking of
publishing a collection of great
Washington letters every time we write a
series people out there respond not only
in Philadelphia but all across the
country they'll write a letter to their
member of Congress or they'll write a
letter to the White House and they'll
get a response and they thoughtfully
send all the correspondence along to us
and it's going to make a view this is a
future retirement plan it's going to
make a great multi volume collection of
letters one of the packages we got in
the mail just last week was a 100 page
plus internal White House memorandum
prepared on America what went wrong in
December of 1991 in which the White
House staff went through everything in
this series and analyzed it and it was a
I will read a whole hundred pages but
there was just one graph that kind of
jumped out which was interesting it said
while there are many allegations in the
series that are factually wrong there
are others ie the special favors that
Congress grants to itself such as
inflation adjusted pensions with which
we would agree
it seems that basically when you go
through the hundred pages those those
points that are raised in the series in
the book with which the White House
agreed were all accurate and those
points with which they didn't agree were
statistically wrong it was somewhat like
a small group of people who said that
the middle class really isn't sure is
shrinking but that's because of all the
upward mobility and they pointed to the
fact that there are more millionaires
than ever now and they're absolutely
right we went back and looked at the tax
returns for 1980 to 1989 and the number
of returns filed by families and
individuals with incomes of more than a
million dollars went up from four
thousand four hundred and fourteen to
sixty 1987 or an increase of thirteen
hundred and four percent which is a
clearly an indication of everyone
becoming a millionaire except if you
look at it in a different way and you
see that the increase in terms of total
returns filed went from point zero zero
four seven two point zero five five two
which means in 187 years if everyone
hangs in there a full 1% of the tax
returns will be filed by millionaires
and if you can hang in for nineteen
hundred years it'll be ten percent but
that's not an inflation adjusted dollars
and unfortunately with the exception of
our first series which was published in
1971 The Inquirer has reprinted
everything we've ever done in a tabloid
format and in the request for those
reprints generally have ranged between
twenty and fifty thousand traditionally
the reprints are delayed about three to
four weeks after the completion of the
series
but this time ex-king the new editor
decided he wanted the reprints available
the day the series ended and so the
reprint was literally tagged onto the
final press run of part 9 and they ran
off 18,000 copies and on with a little
box that day in the final installment
saying the reprints were available in
the Inquirer Lobby the next day we got a
call from the security people saying you
might want to come down and look because
they had to bring in extra security
people just to control the crowds not
because they were unruly or anything
like that because there were so many
people trying to get into the building
we took that where the green assault
went down and never went out the front
door for the next two weeks the 18,000
were gone in two days and I think the
statistics now are fairly well known
that there overall there were 400,000
distributed and we received well over
20,000 letters from all but about two or
three states what is not so well known
as this and this is very important for
you reporters who might want to go back
and talk to editors who might be
frustrated marketing executives menu
masquerading as editors that the
circulation of the paper for nine days
went up every single day as many as
10,000 a day at the end of the series it
dropped back down but we did receive
many letters from people who said they
had not subscribed the paper before but
did so now and letters from a couple
that said we bought three copies each
day and gave the two other copies of the
series to friends there was one major
disappointment from this series of Bill
Moyers did two one-hour programs based
on an adaptation this reason when we
were going through this process we
thought wow this is it this is a big
meal ticket to the really good money of
the electronic media we're going to be
out of here
and everything was really going well
until the day the first program aired
and now we know what it's like to be
savaged by the news media and it was bad
enough we were savaged but their own
paper The Enquirer TV critic reviewed it
and said everybody should watch these
programs that are really great and then
he did this truly malicious thing and I
want to read this so get the words
exactly right he says because we got to
remember now we forget we're going to be
the Siskel and Ebert of economic news he
says he says on the TV personality scale
Bartlett and steel are so laid back is
to be almost completely horizontal and
then I mean we never did anything to
this guy as far as I know but then he
got really personal he says at one point
Bartlett gets so outraged that he
actually arches an eyebrow and then he
concluded by saying the two of them are
Clarke Kennish enough to make Bill
Moyers look like Morton Downey jr. and
at that point we sent a letter to a
Moyers asking if you'd like to join in
litigation but one of our lawyer friends
pointed out the truth is still an
absolute defense so wised against a
gentle talk a little bit more about the
response
want to talk a little bit about the
reaction to the series and now the
subsequent reaction now that the book is
out there because it we think it says a
lot for our profession and also has a
great deal to say about the American
public as well don alluded to these
twenty thousand letters that we received
there was a certain quality to the
response both in the letters and in the
phone calls that we received right after
the original series he had an
astonishing volume of this mail began
coming in phone lines were jamming The
Inquirer switchboard some of the letters
and requests came in by the most bizarre
manner some were written on the back of
wine labels from the Napa Valley in
California one request for reprints was
scribbled on the back of the marching
song on Wisconsin one day after the
series originally appeared a frantic
caller came called from the fella
Manning the switchboard thinks it was
somewhere in the Midwest and said he had
heard by word of mouth that there was
this series that The Inquirer had done
on the American economy by two fellows
by the name of Bartles and Jaymes
this good natured flirt later sent him a
copy of the reprint and he says he threw
in a 6-pack of a peach wine cooler as
well wherever that gentleman is we will
thank him for his support you know what
what accounts for this reaction I mean
we keep being asked that and we ask
ourselves that question and the most I
think obvious thing that we've concluded
the others have actually concluded is
that this has hit a chord among a great
number of American people not just
blue-collar people not just white color
people not just people who have been
hurt in the last generation but many
who've actually benefited from some of
the rules changes but who are now
concerned for one reason or another
about the direction of the country the
interesting thing which I want to speak
to just briefly today is that the reason
this particular subject has hit a chord
and that it did so in by using
techniques and processes a journalism
that supposedly nobody wants to read
anymore this thing was long 73 thousand
words in the original form it's now
considerably longer in the book form it
was filled with numbers it dealt with
the economy taxation fiscal policy the
federal deficit all of these things that
supposedly we are over and over again
that readers don't want to read about
but not only did America what went wrong
contain an abundance of this kind of
information but in these 20 thousand
letters and in these scores and scores
of phone calls we got people pointed
precisely to those numbers those
statistics as giving what one called the
hard facts as to what has happened in
the country this was from an owner of a
small business in Pennsylvania who wrote
us you have articulated what so many of
us have had a gut feeling about but lack
the statistics to prove a Miami woman
wrote this is what newspapers are all
about information helping to explain
what's going on in our lives and part as
and as part of the larger picture and
research
statistics not just hearsay and historia
Oregon man after praising the paper for
both the scope of the enterprise and
also particularly for the numbers it
included said very simply this is what
journalism needs to be doing yet for all
of this the notion seems to exist in our
business that people don't want to read
about these things they're not
interested in numbers they're not
interested in depth and we to this day
remain baffled by that particular notion
we can't figure out why it is so complex
is it so complicated that people do not
understand that after tax reform in 1986
those earning a million or more received
on average a tax cut of two hundred
eighty one thousand while those making
forty to fifty received on average a tax
cut of four hundred dollars why is that
so complicated why is it so complicated
to explain to people that manufacturing
jobs increased in the 50s the 60s and
the 70s the total number decreased in
the 1980s why is that so so complicated
we believe people are capable of
absorbing numbers information that sort
but you can't just spew it out you have
to put it in some kind of a context we
heard bill greider talk about this very
eloquently just a couple of weeks ago
and he makes the point that so much of
the press fails to bring its message
into focus because it doesn't bring the
subject into perspective and and he
fails as he put it to provide a context
for what we tell readers and one that at
least gives them some plausible
connection to their own lives we see
examples of this all around us all the
time recently we've seen this debate
over the balanced budget amendment and
people are made quite a big issue
writing about this and reporting it but
few if any of these stories make the
point that this whole debate is in
effect the fifth time we've been dealing
with this issue since 1974 there have
been four previous measures enacted to
deal with a balanced budget and since
that time there have been 18 consecutive
budget deficits ten of them record
breakers obviously we
from a legislative standpoint have
become more preoccupied with passing
measures that supposedly will balance
the budget than with ballast and
balancing the budget well we've always
believed that people could absorb
numbers and listen to hard facts and
respond to them frankly we never had the
documentary evidence like we did as a
result of this series with these 20,000
letters and these letters are an
astonishing outpouring from the American
people all over the country all walks of
life rich poor and as Don said black
white Hispanic no simple way to describe
them they show very much the hopes the
dreams the concerns that so many people
have for the country and I think most
interesting of all to us their optimism
and in closing I'd like to read you just
the comments of one woman from
Pennsylvania who wrote us about America
what went wrong and what she said was
very symbolic of what literally hundreds
of others wrote us after thanking the
newspaper for investing the time and the
effort she said quite simply there are a
lot of good people who care and who want
to do something to turn this situation
around most of them are mute you to have
opened a Pandora's box of trouble and
grief that the heavies have been sitting
on for a long time
but I think you have pinched the
conscience of the silent majority and
hopefully something very positive will
result thank you so much we'd be happy
to answer some questions that you may
have
thank you for those remarks a questioner
wants to know what is the state of
investigative reporting today 20 years
after Watergate this is a question we
are constantly especially from younger
people coming into the business because
they get a lot of gloom and doom out
there and since I'm older I can tell
people that the gloom and doom is not
warranted the reason there is a there's
a sense that investigative reporting is
not as as great or as prevalent as it
once was is based on what people are
looking at in metropolitan newspapers
and metropolitan newspapers have never
ever been a gauge of the state of
investigative reporting in this country
there is probably not probably there is
more investigative reporting on medium
size and small daily newspapers going on
in this country now and at any time in
this nation's history and if you attend
a convention like Ayari or other
conventions where you see this work the
sad fact is that this these projects are
never pulled together in one place where
we can see them we never know about them
until you go out to a convention or or
hear someone someone call you and send
you one the volume of this work and the
quality of it is mind-boggling
and if it really should put most
metropolitan newspapers to shame they
should be embarrassed by it because the
observations that are being made on the
on the health of investigative reporting
really are based on what metropolitan
newspapers are doing but they've never
they never historically did that much to
begin with
so we think that basically the future is
very very bright
what specific training do you recommend
for young reporters for example
accounting or research methods one of
the nice things about doing something
like this you never know what kind of
questions you're going to be hit by
there's this is an interesting debate in
our profession about specialized
training and while I don't think either
one of us would ever discourage any type
of specialized training in a way we can
almost go too far in certain areas but I
think for young reporters I think Don
and I are both pretty much in agreement
on this rather than trying to foresee
and conceive your specialty early on you
should still get a broad-based training
in your field whether it's radio TV the
print media because only by seeing how
government works at all its levels to
get a full appreciation of how our
system as a whole operates the two of us
spent years laboring and what a famous
composer once described as the galleys
referring to all of it that hard work
you do day in and day out to churn out
stories we both spent years and years
doing daily stories of a wide variety on
a wide variety of subjects had nothing
to do with long-range reporting had
nothing to do with enterprise reporting
and I am most thankful for all the time
I spent doing that because I learned how
local school boards operate I've seen
how local City Councils operate I've
seen how what local political races are
like at the grassroots level you see and
absorb an appreciation of democracy
that's invaluable to your work at
whatever level you may pursue it so we
are firm believers and starting at small
medium sized papers definitely not at
large institutions if possible
we have two questions on the same theme
now that you know what went wrong to you
since the nation is turning the
situation around and your book documents
tremendous job losses due to mergers and
acquisitions and deregulation is this
still happening and where let me try
there let's see these are the book
documents tremendous job losses these
are continuing to happen I mean in
deregulation alone when Trans World
Airlines and America West and
Continental all entered bankruptcy some
time back everybody assumed that they
would all emerge at some point the
stories are becoming increasingly gloomy
for those airlines if not emerging at
least in some reduced fashion from what
they used to be what we see we see a
continuing fallout through the 1990s
largely because of some of the excesses
that were built up in the 1980s when you
look at the size of the corporate debt
loads that so many companies took on in
the 1980s we're going to be paying that
price for a long time it's even it's
hitting companies that otherwise are
very solid companies Macy's is probably
an excellent example of that Macy's is
basically from Olin what anyone can see
a very solid company but because of the
excessive debt that it took on in the
1980s as part of that gogo philosophy as
to why debt was good and made companies
cleaner and leaner and meaner and so
forth Macy's is now in bankruptcy and
starting to close stores starting to lay
off people so we see a continuing
weakness throughout the 90s one of the
interesting statistics that's in the
book that absolutely stunned us before
1994 1980 there were two bankruptcies in
the u.s. two corporate bankruptcies
where the companies had assets of two of
one billion or more since 1985 alone
there had been more than four dozen
bankruptcies for the
companies had assets of more than 1
billion or more most of those just in
recent years is a two-page chart in the
book on these bankruptcies the books
been out two months the charts already
out of date because there have been at
least two more billion dollar-plus
bankruptcies since then so that's going
to continue unfortunately to happen just
add one other thing to that and that's
that we talked about that all through
the 80s the the explanation you heard
for what was happening was we were
increasing shareholder value the 90s and
you see it every day in the newspaper
when you pick it up it's the global
economy and that there is very little
difference between the results of those
two phrases but the consequence is
growing out of those two phrases they
really mean lost jobs and for reporters
we hardly recommend that when somebody
tells you that moving a plant overseas
is going to create X number of jobs in
this country that a year later you go
back and say where precisely are those
jobs if they were created you can find
them if anybody wants to bother to look
do you sense that the nation is turning
the situation around and have you come
up with a series or other solutions for
the plight of the middle class which
seems to be shrinking as a result of
what you've described this is the the
one question we get all the time and I
think our answer has been very
consistent we're short term passiveness
and long term optimist the short term
pessimism has to do with the probability
that things are going to have to get
much worse before they get better
that may not be true but it tends to
look that way on the other hand I think
we're both very optimistic about the
American people and you can't help when
you spend as much time as we did going
around the country and one of the fun
things and the fascinating things not
necessarily fun but fascinating and very
instructive things from the book is
we've done about no more than 75 radio
talk shows now and half the states in
the country technology is such that
unfortunately we never have to leave the
Inquirer to do this we just sit in the
office rather than getting to travel but
the questions that come in in these I
mean we've been in the business long
enough as you people many of you people
have you can sort out the whack jobs of
very very quickly you know when the
questioner is a serious person and you
know when you're dealing with someone
who is really very concerned and this is
across the board it doesn't matter
whether it's a small town as we did a
radio station in Streeter Illinois that
had the mayor on along with the talk
show host or or Michael Jackson in Los
Angeles or or any of the programs in
Boston in New York the questions that
are coming in there are very similar to
what we found when we went out and did
the interviews around the country that
produced a series people are concerned
and they want to see something done and
clearly what's happening now is they're
casting about trying to find out what
the best way is to do that
I want to preface this story with a this
question with a story that mr. bralette
told me he said that his editors don't
like to ask them any questions about
their their work because they'll say
that's a very good question
and they'll come back two days later and
the story will be 90 inches longer the
question is did your editors cut any
good stuff
there's a funny story that max King
tells about this it's probably the best
one and that is in the original series
was picked up by roughly 50 newspapers
around the country at least that we know
of some picked up one part some picked
up two or three parts some ran actually
all nine parts but reduce them somewhat
and at one gathering we once we once
made the point that none of them of
course ran the series in entirety to
which max jumped up and said nobody ran
it in entirety including the
Philadelphia Enquirer like all of us
there were many good parts that
obviously you have to go through a
synthesis process and some of this
actually found their way back into the
book we also received many wonderful
tips from people around the country some
wonderful ideas about things to expand
on that we were unaware of so the book
also served as a mini follow-up to some
parts of the series so yes there's
always a synthesis process that that
goes through but nothing of real great
substance that in any way reduced the
impact or the significance of what we
felt the story was about was was left
out
the one questioner wants to know to what
degree do you connect the rise of Ross
Pro to your series or maybe another way
of asking this is are you seeing your
work recycled in the rhetoric of the
political campaign this year the Ross
Perot wins an interesting when sitting
in the office a few weeks after the
series ran and the phone rings and I
pick it up and he says I say Bartlett
and he says Don he said this is Ross
Perot and I said right
figured it was some friend but it really
was him and it's clear now when you look
back all those months what was happening
at the time because he said what he
wanted to do with the reprints was put
them into a restaurant that he goes to
every day not far from his home or a
couple of days a week which is basically
a restaurant that attracts a solid
middle-class group of people blue collar
white collar and he wanted to gauge the
reaction of the people who read the
reprint in the restaurant that was back
in November I don't think there's any
question you see large parts of it
coming out I think one of the we haven't
seen Governor Clinton's the full
proposal but just what we read in the
newspaper the tax part of it clearly
comes right out of the book when he's
talking about foreign corporations not
paying a share of taxes that they should
pay in this country and when he talks
about raising taxes at the top end of
the scale most of the tax policy issues
look like they came out of the book and
and other issues as well one last thing
I might add part of the appeal he's
having too is clearly a part of a
widespread disenchantment that we're
seeing around the country I'm sure many
of you are as well with both both
parties and there's no doubt that that
has to do with a lot of why he's getting
response he is people are so fed up
rightly or wrongly with what they
perceived to be the way both parties
have handled economic issues in
and the way government is operated in
Washington that's probably the single
most widespread reason for a lot of this
appeal a questioner asked in this age of
databases and power journalism what
resources did you rely on for your
information a library a computer your
car good question we used a lot of
databases electronic databases and we
have for years on a whole wide range of
things we used an electronic database
several years ago to decode one of the
special tax breaks and the tax reform
activator that was proposed after the
tax reform act of 86
so databases represent a wonderful
resource out there but most the most
significant probably database we used
was one we created ourselves rather than
buying material from somebody else we
simply one of the most exciting things
we do is to input data on a computer or
PC and all the charts in the book and
the series before that which would
capture the attention of so many people
were based on basically a very tedious
painstaking process I give an example 1
shows salaries and wages of people by
income groups in the 1980s for example
it's a very dramatic chart that shows
the increase of people earning more than
1 million what their cumulative
increases were versus people 20 to
50,000 the heart of the middle-class
very small increase that's based on ten
years of statistics of income from the
Internal Revenue Service or each one of
those reports is xeroxed or obtained
from the IRS and the particular numbers
input in a computer and then analyzed
some of the data we went back to the 30s
and 40s analyzing corporate payments and
tax collections each one input a
year-by-year
exciting stuff right
but tedious work but absolutely at the
heart of what you ultimately end up with
which is a very dramatic chart and
example so the computer in that sense
has become a tremendously important tool
for us other than that our techniques by
which we organize material and store it
and keep track of it are basically very
old-fashioned we don't have
sophisticated filing systems we file
information simply by subject matter
company individual general subject area
the single most valuable tool we know of
is the oldest tool that exists in
civilization and that is to reread the
material how many times do you
transcribe an interview or watch
something you've seen before and there's
something new in it the same thing is
true of a written document a written
report you see that over and over again
the mind can only focus on so many
things so we try to basically read and
reread our own material whether it's
transcribed interviews government
reports findings from databases and that
is served us better than any single
technique over the years is there an
advantage to having a dual investigative
team I think the the advantage is
obviously going to do twice as much work
the other real advantage and we see this
a lot of times with people working on
their first project or two is when two
people are working together you can
bounce things off one another you can
you've got someone to talk to and the
one thing we see quite often with the
person doing it alone who hasn't done it
a lot is they sometimes get lost because
it's not that they don't know what they
want to do or they don't know how to do
it sometimes you just need to sit down
and talk a problem through with someone
and someone say why are you talking to
me this you just solve your you just
answered your question that's really one
of the great advantages of two people on
the other hand
we see it over and over and over again
with editors who say well I'm just going
to match this man over here and this
woman this is going to be a great team
and can't figure out why it doesn't work
you two are famous in journalism for
going years between bylines I was
wearing do you feel deadline pressure
one you know when you're ready and our
people pushing you to get into print
before then Jim has a great response to
this he says when that's the other
question it comes up all the time from
journalism students when do you know
when you're finished and this is his
which I could claim it was mine he said
well we got a red light over the desk
and it flashes and a clacks and signs
and it says the end is here no there's a
there unkind people who have pointed out
to us that that we've out let our
projects about lasted to editors at the
Enquirer you know which is true when
John McMullen the first editor who had
hired us we started a Criminal Court
series under John he left and gene
Roberts inherited it and then we started
this America what went wrong under Jean
Roberts and he left and max King came
and we don't know what's going to happen
next but know the essence of this
business is deadlines daily journalism
and that's why many people who think
they want to do this work once they get
into it really don't because you really
it's a different kind of mindset and is
Jim indicated we both spent our early
years in the business doing daily
reporting and we just find this much
more fascinating much more interesting
several questions just arrived on the
series and the economics of it in view
of the strength of foreign competition
was the restructuring of the US economy
avoidable or is what you've documented
primarily the result of the Reagan
Republican policies of the Reagan Bush
administration's I think the first thing
to say anyone who reads the book in the
series before that realizes that the
Democrats don't come out looking very
good in this either I mean many of the
deregulation policies which have had
such an adverse effect on many
middle-class Americans date from the
late 70s and even many of the measures
enacted for the S&L industry were pushed
by Democrats so it's been a joint
arrangement here that has led us to this
particular situation in terms of the
argument on the restructuring was this
restructuring avoidable or necessary if
you're talking about companies that were
ticketed for oblivion our industries
that were ticketed for oblivion that's
one thing but what we saw over and over
again in which we wrote about in the
story was we're not industries were not
factories that were necessarily
inefficient or unprofitable we've never
forgotten one in Missouri outside of st.
Louis where the restructuring which was
brought on but when a corporate raider
made a run at the company in the company
to buy off that the Raiders loaded up on
debt and when they could not manage the
debt they had to start selling assets
generating cash to pay down that debt
they had to do that in a hurry and one
of those plants that was closed right
away it was one of the most profitable
and well-run in the company simply
because the corporation owned the land
owned the machinery and could quickly
turn that around so you had from so much
of the restructuring not laying the
groundwork for a long-term improvement
in the in the country but almost an
exacerbation of this short-term
psychology that gripped the country so
much in the 1980s
do you get any sense that the
intellectual underpinnings behind the
regulation are eroded enough that that
could be changed in regulation some
deregulated industries brought back
under regulation both you can't turn the
clock back once things like this
happened but it's interesting to
contrast what's happening with the
Europeans now I know if anybody saw the
stories today about airline deregulation
in Europe if all you read were the
headlines you would think gee the
Europeans are going the same route that
we did in this country with the airlines
but and we haven't seen the actual
papers yet but if you look at if you
read some of the fine print in terms of
the airline deregulation in Europe it's
considerably different because the
national governments are all going to
have a hand and a say-so to make sure
not destructive price wars do not
develop and if you look at what's
happened in the US does it make any
sense to create and then run out of
business in a short number of years X
number of Airlines you never had an
airline bankruptcy in this country
before deregulation of the airline
industry in 1978 since then as everybody
knows six major carriers alone have gone
out of business many others are in
bankruptcy we're clearly moving toward a
concentration in the airline industry
unless no one denies that the original
idea of deregulation which was promoting
competition is not going to work so why
you can't turn that back probably the
most important thing is to watch the
future things like banking and other
industries to make sure many of the
mistakes made there in the past are not
repeated in the future
question-it wants to know what is the
sequel to this series I'm not sure we
want to answer that a room full of
reporters uh we got so many questions
during the series from people basically
turned around the issue of forum trade
exports and imports and this again goes
to the heart of really very thoughtful
people out there and we had a call from
one woman who this was right around
Christmas and she came back with his
entire Christmas list of things she had
bought and she said I want to know why
they're being made there I want to know
what the consequences were for the
people who used to make these products
here and the one that really got our
attention when she read around she said
I bought this bra and it says
manufactured in the Dominican Republic
from components made in the US and she
said could you explain that to me and I
said we'll find out
today the Press Club gave out a great
many journalism awards honoring and
recognizing the work of journalists from
around the country have the awards that
you won have they motivated you in your
work does journalism need more or fewer
awards and contests I think the greatest
motivation we get is from readers and
that was that's why this series in
particular was so important to us
because when you spend two years in a
project we had no idea what was going to
happen when max King we asked max the
The Inquirer had never before been a
series more than seven parts never
carried over into a second week and when
we made the case with max we wanted to
go nine parts so we're going into two
weeks this was something had never been
done before and he he said I want to
think about it overnight came back the
next day and said we'll do it
everybody was rolling the dice in this
series in a way not only in terms of
length in in the word count but in the
number of parts was the question
oh the prizes now it's it's really the
response of people interestingly
jean-robert's who was so responsible for
carving out the enquires tradition has a
theory especially in terms of us he
doesn't believe that our best series
ever won the major awards and he usually
cites our energy series nuclear waste
and the very earlier when we did was a
computerized study of the violent crime
in Philadelphia it was the first time a
computer had ever been used on that
scale by a newspaper and phil meyer did
the programming for us we actually
leased the computer down here out in
maryland at the navy used to track it
ships that's a large the computer was at
that time he had to punch all the
information and i-iv em cards when that
was in urge for a Pulitzer had never
made it past the editor who said he
didn't think the newspaper should ever
use computers and I think that's why you
never ever ever do things for prize as
you do them because there is a there's a
need to inform people and you're looking
for the response from readers not
anything else
because you spend as much time as anyone
rummaging around the public record
looking for information I wonder if you
could tell us what the state is of open
records laws today and specifically a
question from someone here are you
disturbed by the control private firms
designated by the federal government
have over computerized government
records not sure we can answer this with
a great deal of authority only because
the problem with records it is a
continuing one in every agency at all
times we have been the biggest obstacle
we have been confronted over the years
is not so much the access to records but
is finding the records and then trying
to make sense of them and use of them
once once you you find them because
we've used heavily public records public
documents over over time and people are
under the misunderstanding that because
we use them we know where everything is
that there's some magical book or
process that lets you know exactly where
you can go it's called knowing where to
look and people ask us this all the time
well we never know where to look unless
we're going back to exactly the same
kind of record or document that we have
used in the past
so this best advice we can give to
anybody dealing with records at all
levels of government is a very simple
one so many clerks and bureaucracies
whether they be local or state or
federal are very orderly in their
behavior and their activities they like
to have clean desks and if you want
something that you think they have just
stick there with them you become an
obstacle to the efficient operation of
their enterprise and they've been
amazing to us how many times when
somebody says something isn't available
something is not there then when you
continue to asking what is this based on
what is the regulation what is the law
politely nicely how eventually they come
around to your way of thinking say yes I
checked it is in fact available go do it
but there's no simple solution for
getting around that other than to ask
people specific
what it is that they're using to deny
you that information before I ask the
final question I'd like to present you
both with certificates of appreciation
from the National Press Club and
something you'll find handy back in
Philadelphia the official National Press
Club coffee mug it really does work
questioner says you took a swipe at
editors who you really think or
marketeers could you please elaborate on
that at length gee we can do this for
the next 24 hours we're talking about
people who say that the editor people
are editors who say that people don't
want to read stories or more than 18
inches long or 10 inches long they don't
want to read a story off the jump
there's one it's always hung out there
the president of a large metropolitan
newspaper sent out a memo saying that
words to that effect that people didn't
want to read long stories and they
especially did not want to read the
traditionally dull boring government
stories that newspapers have always
covered and our response basically to
that is there are no dull boring stories
they're only dull boring reporters
editors and most importantly publishers
who don't recognize the difference out
there and earn trying to to create a
product that people really don't want it
and I'll give you another example here
on these radio talk shows and we've also
talked I don't know two dozen audiences
around the country League of Women
Voters groups like that people who are
clearly sophisticated people who read
and every single place we have talked
the question has been raised what is
wrong with the news media why are
newspapers radio television covering the
issues that affect our lives and we have
an answer to that and it is basically
that this marketing people are tell
editor's or the editors are believing
them that people don't want information
anymore nothing really has ever changed
in this business it was back in in the
early 1930s when Stanley Walker was the
legendary editor of the New York Herald
Tribune said very simply facts sell
newspapers nothing has changed since
then except the perception on some part
of some people that maybe it isn't
working anymore and that's been really
the most rewarding thing about this
series because at least it has caught
the attention of a few editors who said
gee maybe people really do want to read
I'd like to thank you for coming to
today's luncheon once in and again
congratulations to all the Award winners
here today and thanks also to the judges
who helped find our Award winners thank
you all for coming